مساء الخير كده الصوت جاهز اخباركم ايه
انا سعيد جدا موجود النهارده معكم انا
زي ما قلت مش جايه اقول لكم خمس حاجات
للنجاح او ثلاث حاجات هتعملها وهتبقى غيره
انا هقول لك النهارده ازاي تعمل بتاعك
وازاي تعمل نجاحك بايدك
الاكواد اللي هتكتبها بايدك عشان نجاحك
انت لان نجاحي غير نجاحك فانا هقول لك
ازاي الطريقه اللي انت المفروض
[موسيقى]
وازاي ترسمها وازاي تكتب الكود بتاع
النجاح بتاعك اول حاجه اعرفكم بنفسي انا
اسلام نصر الله دكتور صيدلي كثير منكم
ممكن ما يعرفونيش
يعني بدات حياتي كصيدلي عادي
اخدت ماجستير اداره اعمال معايا دلوقتي
بحضر في الدكتوراه فكرت كتير جدا اللي انا
اعرف نفسي بايه لقيت احسن حاجه اللي انا
داعم للتحول الرقمي والذكاء الاصطناعي
يعني في دول الشرق الاوسط
القصه دي طلعتني من صيدله لحد ما ابقى كده
واللي انا بحب اعرف نفسي كده لان اكتر من
يعني ما بحبش اعرف نفسي كباحث ولا كاتب
ولا
صانع محتوى لا بالعكس او رائد اعمال او
رجل اعمال لا انا شايف ان ده التعريف
بتاعي دلوقتي
وبدا ازاي ان انا بدات من صغري من وانا
عندي 11 سنه اشتغل مع اني اسرتي كانت
ماسوره الحال ونقدر يعني اعمل حاجات كثير
بمساعده والدي بس انا رفضت ده حسيت ان ده
هيديني قيمه حقيقيه حسيت ان ده اللي انا
محتاجه فعلا اللي انا اجيب موبايلي بنفسي
اجيب عربيتي بنفسي مش حد يجيبها لي ودي
اللي هتخلي حياتي قيمه وعلى الاساس ده
بدات اشتغل من سنه صغير وبعدين فكرت اروح
الخليج ورحت مع شركه عالميه في الادويه
واخذوني من الشركه محليه هنا في مصر ودي
نادر لما بتحصل ان انت تنتقل من شركه
محليه لشركه عالميه بره بره مصر بسهوله لا
وكفاءه لقوا شغل معين لو اصرار على النجاح
بشكل معين جت 2004 حصلت الصدمه الصدمه
كانت مشكله في الشركه حصلت لي على اثرها
قعدت تسع سنين
متغرب بدون اقامه بدون باسبور في مشاكل
كثيره
مالهاش اول ولا اخر حسيت في يوم من الايام
اللي انا عايش في كابوس ومش يعني اصحى منه
قعدت افكر ازاي ممكن اغير حياتي ومن
المسؤول عن ده بطلت الوم الشركه بطلت الوم
من المجتمع بطلت الوم دوله بطلت الوم من
القوانين قلت انا المسؤول الوحيد على
الوضع اللي انا فيه مش حد تاني وانا
المسؤول عن تغييره مش حد ثاني
كنت بفكر ازاي اطلع من ده وازاي احل
المشكله دي فبدات بموضوع الاكواد بدات
اكتب اكواد لنفسي للنجاح بتاعي وازاي اطلع
من ده اول ما شيلت اللوم عن اي جهه اخرى
وقلت انا المسؤول عن الوضع ده حياتي بدات
تتغير بدات اتغير 180 درجه في تفكيري وفي
طريقتي عرفت ان هي مش منحه مش محنه لا هي
منحه وربنا اداني منحه عظيمه اللي انا
اكتشف قدراتي وكل واحد فيكم كده برضه مش
لازم تمر بمقاسات كبيره عشان تعرف قيمه
نفسك او قيمه الكفاءه اللي عندك وقيمه
قدراتك مش لازم خالص انت ممكن اعملها
سيموليشن كده في في الباك اند في مخك ونفذ
اللي انت يطلع لك بعد كده مش لازم ان انا
يحصل لي حادثه عشان اعرف قيمه الحزام
الامان ده خلاص انا اتخيل ان انا لو مش
لابس حزام امان هو من هنا بدات فكره
المايد مامج والكودنج اللي انا بعمله في
تفكيري وفي طريقه ادائي بعد كده بدات احط
كود ان كلمه مستحيل هي دافع لك للنجاح اول
ما اسمع حد بيقول لي مستحيل اعرف ان ده
الحافز او الكود بتاعي اللي انا انجح
بحبها بقيه الكلمه دي اول ما اسمع ده اعرف
اللي فيه فرصه لنجاحي ليه بدات افكر كده
لان كان بيقولوا زمان مستحيل نطلع للقمر
وطالعوا للقمر بمنتهى البساطه كانوا
بيقولوا الطيران ده حاجه صعبه ومستحيل
تحصل يعني حاجه في احلامنا والناس برضو
عارفه تطير وبقت طيران مغير وش الكره
الارضيه كلها فحلم مش ابعد من الطيران ولا
ابعد من القمر يعني حلمي متواضع اقل من
كده بكثير يكون عندي 14 علامه تجاريه بس
شويه حاجات كده بس لقيت ده سهل وبسيط
وممكن يتعمل مجرد ما شلت شويه مفاهيم
وحطيت شويه اكواد الكود التاني اللي حطيته
اللي انا ابدا اراجع ثاني الحاجات اللي
كنت بسمعها زمان كنت اشوف
حد زي دكتور ابراهيم الفقي او دلكر نيجي
رجعت اقرا الكتب بتاعتهم تاني لقيت نفس
الكلام اللي انا كنت بقراه قبل كده هو هو
بس بمعنى مختلف بمعنى جديد خالص اول مره
اشوفه مع انه كان مكتوب في الكتاب
وبالطريقه الصح بس انا ما كنتش عيني
جايباه كنت بظن اللي هو لا ده مش موجود
المنحه اللي ربنا اداها لي دي تسع سنين
كامله مش عارف اتحرك مش عارف ارجع مصر مش
عارف كل ده خليتني اقرا الكلام ده لقيته
مختلف فعلا لقيت حاجه جديده فعلا فيه مع
انه مكتوب بس قريته بشكل مختلف قدر يطورني
وقدر يطلع قدراتي الحقيقيه ناس كثير كنا
يعني كنا بنصنف الديسابيلتي او الناس اللي
عندها محتاجه مساعده ان هم الناس اللي
عنده ايد او رجل فيها مشكله او اسبينال
كورد او كذا لقيتهم بعد تفكير بسيط جدا ان
دي سبيلتي هي موجوده هنا
مش في حته تانيه
وبتكون امتى يعني لازم تاخد الوصف ده لما
يكون اعضائك سليمه ومخك سليم وكل حاجه فيك
سليمه ومش عارف تنجح ومش عايز تزق نفسك
للنجاح او تقول مش قادر او تقول مستحيل دي
المفروض الفئه دي اللي تاخد 5% في الشركات
وتتعامل بالطريقه دي مش الناس دي اللي
تاخدلتي او تتصنت بالمنظر ده هو نوع واحد
من اللي موجود هنا
كل اطرافك سليمه وكل حاجتك سليمه وانت
موقفها وموقف قدراتك ان كلمه مستحيل هي
البارير بتاعك اللي موقفك في في نجاحك وفي
مستقبلك بدات اشوف الناس دي كل الناس دي
يعرف التنجح بدات اتحول من شخص يعني شاره
للاكل عمال اطلع غلي في الاكل اتفضلوا
معانا صحيح
تقريبا كانت بليله او حاجه كده بس مش فاكر
بس كان دي مطعتي الوحيده دي الحاجه اللي
بتخليني انبسط بدات احول نفسي لشخص ثاني
خالص اركب عجل العب رياضه انام بدري واصحى
بدري بدات ابني حياتي بشكل مختلف بد احب
الحياه بشكل مختلف بدات ادائي بيتحسن
بحاجات كتير جدا اتغيرت حياتي واخذت
القرار ده اللي انا مستحيل افضل كده وكلمه
مستحيل بقت تتريجر بتاعي بدات بعد كده من
شخص مش عارف يعلم عياله مش عارف يطلع
شهادات ميلاد لعياله لان ابني عدى الاربع
سنين من غير ما يكون عندي شهاده ميلاد
بنتي مش عارف اطلع لها شهادات التخرج لحد
ما بنتي دلوقتي بتدرس في الجامعه
الامريكيه هنا وكان داخل حلم كبير ليا فين
شهد
ووقف بتكلم في الجامعه الامريكيه من بعد
ما كنت فاقد الامل وبحلم بكوابيس كل يوم
الصبح اقول انا لا مش هنجح هجيب لك امتى
صحيح
في حد بيقول تجيبها لنفسها بقى خلاص انا
طلعت بره الموضوع كده تمام بدات ابص
للموضوع بشكل فعلا اللي انا اهو عرفنا
نعمل حاجه من حد محبوس مش عارف يطلع من
بره المدينه اللي هو ساكن فيها لحد عارف
يعمل حاجات حاجات كثير كانت الجرايد بتكتب
ازاي نساعد الصيدلي اللي محبوس في
السعوديه اللي مش عارف يطلع اللي بيتعرض
لظلم اللي لحد ما وصلت لليونايتد وحقوق
الانسان وازاي نحوله او نطلعه بس يطلع يشم
هواء لحد شخص عنده 14 علامه تجاريه 7
شركات اربع برات اختراع او ملكيه فكريه في
السوفت وير
مصانع
ده المستحيل المستحيل اللي قلت عليه مش
ابعد من القمر
ده المستحيل اللي قلت عليه مش ابعد من
القمر لشخص قادر يعمل كل الحاجات اللي كان
نفسي اعملها ومحروم منها لان شيلت شويه
اكواد حطيت شويه اكواد غيرت بتاعي لحد ما
يبقى عندي كذا فرع لحد ما يبقى عندي كميه
شحنات
وشركاء نجاح بانوا معايا الشركه
وعدينا 200 300 موظف او شركاء نجاح بلاش
موظف لان دي الحقيقه الناس دي ساعدوني
اللي احنا بالحجم ده وفي وقته قليل جدا
بالاضافه المؤسسه تطوعيه كبيره
حاليا من راسها بتحول او بتساعد في سوق
العمل اللي احنا ندرب الشباب ونحضرهم لسوق
العمل وبنستهدف 5000 شاب نقول لهم ان ال
ال
المنحه اللي ربنا بيديها لك لازم تستثمرها
وما اسمهاش محنه ابدا هو ربنا بيديها لك
عشان انت ما رضيتش تحط السميليشن اللي
احنا قلنا عليه عشان تعرف ان المستحيل
بيتحقق وده اللي احنا بنيناه واحده واحده
طيب ازاي اعمل بقى وازاي اعمل الاكواد
بتاعتي وان شاء الله هنحولها لتطبيق قريب
وناخد برده عليه ملكيه الفكريه باذن الله
يعني ادعوا لنا بس عشان نزود يبقوا خمس
بدل ما هم اربع مرات اختراع اللي انت ترسم
دواير بس تقول القرار اللي انت عايز تحطه
حطه في دايره وقول النتيجه اللي انت
عايزها او ايه السؤال اللي انت عايز تطلع
بيه بالقرار مثلا انام بدري ولا مانامش
بدري من اول هنا
تبدا ترسم دايره اه احط الدايره طب احط
برانش فوق كده ازاي افكر بشكل ايجابي
وازاي افكر برضو بشكل سلبي اوعى تهمل
الجانب السلبي لانه مهم عشان هو ده
الفرامل بتاعتك وحط الجانب الايجابي
معظمنا بنحط الفرامل بس بنحط الفرامل
لحياتنا ونجاحنا بايدينا احنا وما بنفكرش
غير في السيكونس اللي تحت ده بس لا حط
الجانب الايجابي وابدا ارسم دوائر انا
استفيد ايه لو نمت بدري نمت بدري على فكره
مش اصحى بدري انت بتعالج الروت السبب ما
بيتعالجش النتيجه النتيجه اللي انت بتصحى
متاخر او بتصحى بدري بس الروت انت بتعالج
الروت نفسه الروت ان انا انام بدري ليه
انام بدري لان لو عرفت معلومه زي ان
الهرمونات السعاده كلها بتطلع من من عشره
بالليل لحد 12:00 بالليل بعد كده بتنقص
90% منها وما بتستفيدش منها طب انا اخسر
السعاده ليه هرمونات السعاده دي اللي
بتخليني اقرا واكتب الصبح واروح ازور
قرايبي واعمل نشاطات انا كنت بحلم بيها
بدون هرمون السعاده انت هتبقى شخص مكتئب
مش عايز تتحرك من سريرك عايز تبقى ليزي
قوي وداون جدا طب ليه اخسر حاجه زي كده
حطها في دائره وقل لا انا مش هاخسر ده
وانا حابه نشيط وهعمل حاجه مختلفه حط ان
انا بحب السهر بردو بس المشاعر اديها اقل
درجه ليه عشان انت في كود الكود زي
الكمبيوتر بالظبط زي الذكاء الاصطناعي
الكود اللي هو بتبدا يحركك بسرعه عشان كده
الكمبيوتر بيفكر بسرعه ويطلع النتايج
دقيقه وممكن ساعات بنقول اشطر من انسان هو
مجرد بيحط كود لقيت كذا نفذ من غير ما
تقعد تفكر كثير في الحاجه دي لقيت ان
الصحيان بدري مهم وده
هيساعدك ان انت تبدا يومك بدري طب نام
بدري خلاص خد القرار ونفذ على طول وابدا
حياتك من هنا كل حاجه بقى احطها البس حزام
وانا ما لبسش حزام ولا لازم يكون في مرور
بيعاقبني او بيعمل بينالتيز عليا عشان احط
الحزام لا خلاص ارسمه في دائره برضه احط
البس الحزام ولا لا لا هتلاقي النتيجه كود
البس الحزام المستحيل اقف عنده ولا لا لا
المستحيل بيتحقق وخلي كلمه مستحيل حافز لك
للنجاح خلي كلمه مستحيل واعرف ان صفه من
صفات المستحيل انه بيتحقق وحطها قدامك
ونفذها على طول ما تتاخرش عندها المستحيل
بيتحقق ده كود الاخوات دي كلها هي دي اللي
هتوصلك للنجاح بتاعك مش هتنسى حاجه مش
هتوقع منك حاجه بعد كده هتلاقي نفسك سريع
هتلاقي نفسك حابب الحياه قادر تنتج وتشتغل
قادر تدعم ناس اكتر وتساعد ناس اكثر
وتنبسط في حياتك اكثر وتقدر تحقق كل حاجه
بس هتقول مستحيل ان هي المستحيل التانيه
لا ده مش هتوصلك لحاجه ابدا اخواتنا بقى
نكتبها كده ورا بعض ونبدا نفكر فيها وازاي
ابني حياتي بشكل مختلف واستثمر الوقت اللي
انا بضيعه في السهر او بستثمره في حاجه او
احط المشاعر فاكتور اساسي لحياتي هي تتحكم
فيا اللي انا بحب السهر احطها بس اديها
نسبه اقل نسبه اقل من ثلاثه
ابدا بس احط حاجه زي هرمونات السعاده عشره
من عشره عشان دي اللي هتخليني اصحى واشتغل
وانتج اكتر واوصل للنجاح اللي انا عايزه
وبمنتهى البساطه وما حدش يتخيل ان ده حاجه
صعبه ولا مستحيله ولا بعيد عن ربنا ابدا
حط الاكواد دي وهتلاقي نفسك منتهى السعاده
ومنتهى النشاط ومنتهى الاكتيفيتي انا سعيد
جدا ان انا موجود معكم برده النهارده
اتمنى اكون اضفت حاجه اتمنى اكون عملنا او
كود اللي احنا نستحقه مع بعض ان شاء الله
اللي احنا ننجح ونعمل حاجه لبلدنا ماهربش
ما نفكرش في الاكواد التانيه اللي احنا
لازم نهرب من بلد ونشوف حته تانيه بره ما
فيش ظرف ما فيش قوانين ما فيش حاجه تمنعك
من نجاح انت الوحيد اللي بتمنع نفسك عن
النجاح شكرا ليكم ويمكن سعيد واتمنى دائما
نشوفكم على خير يا رب شكرا جزيلا